principal component analysis is perhaps
the most widely used data reduction
technique on the planet
everyone uses it but here's the thing it
doesn't actually do data reduction
principal component analysis is the idea
of trying to find a different view for
our data in which we can separate it
better and I'll show an example piece of
paper and the idea is that what we want
to try and do is reframe our data maybe
move it around so that we can better
separate things out better cluster
things perhaps it's better for machine
learning now as a side effect of this in
PCA we also order our axes by the most
to least useful in some sense so then we
can perform a separate data reduction
technique later by taking the slightly
less useful axes away by or in this case
dimensions or attributes of our data PCA
is commonly pitched as a data reduction
technique actually it's a data
transformation technique it just makes
our data and meaning able to production
later so let's imagine we have some
attributes and we we know that some are
correlated some are not correlated the
problem is that maybe we don't want to
just delete some of the attributes may
be 0.65 correlation is I mean it's it's
good but it's not it doesn't mean we
definitely want to delete attribute two
and keep only attribute one on the other
hand maybe we do need to reduce some of
the number of dimensions we've got or
maybe we just want to try and make our
data more amenable to things like
clustering so let's look at a quick
example typically PCA is done over many
dimensions when we've got lots and lots
of attributes I'm just going to show two
because obviously I starts to break down
when I try and draw that many on the
page so if we have two attributes and
what we want to try and do is work out
what the contribution of each of these
is to our data set which of these is
useful which of these is not useful and
now obviously if we had many dimensions
you know seven hundred ten thousand we
can still apply the same technique so
maybe we have some data that's like this
we have some datasets over here and
perhaps we have a little gap and maybe
some data over here and in general our
data is kind of increasing like this so
this means that attribute one and
attribute two are positively correlated
to some extent but maybe the correlation
is not so strong that we just wanted
elite attribute to what we want to try
and do
is transform our data into a way where
these are more useful imagine that
you've got some data but looks a bit
like this but if we rotate our data we
take a different view we can see there's
actually two objects and then we can
separate them out and maybe if you were
to take them again you could see there
was four objects and so on this is the
idea what PCA is going to do is find new
axes for this data that separate it
better for PCA to work what we would
start by doing is standardizing our data
so all of our dimensions attribute one
attribute to all of the attributes are
going to be centered around zero and
they're going to have a standard
deviation of one PCA will not work
really at all if you have widely
different scales for your data so what
we want to try and do is find a
direction or an axis through these two
attributes that separates out our data
better than individual attributes do
let's see how this data looks just from
attribute one if we trace down this way
you can see that it's sort of got this
amount of spread in actually Bute one
and they kind of dotted around like this
and they sort of should go all the way
along like this so you can't really see
anything on here meaningful about these
two groups right and of course the more
dimensions you have the more this could
be a problem
similarly about tribute to if we trace
along here it goes from this range to
this range this is the variance of
attribute - like the range and we can
see that roughly speaking the data is as
spread out in attribute one as it is in
attribute to that spread is about the
same and both of them are kind of useful
for looking of a data but not really
because again we have an equal
distribution of point all the way along
here so that's not hugely useful all
right so if we look at just attribute
one that's not hugely helpful if we look
at just attribute two that's not hugely
helpful either so what can we do well
what we want to try and do is find a new
axis like some new attribute that fits
through this data like this and can
really separate everything out because
the spread of this data is actually
diagonally in some sense not this way or
this way so what principal component
analysis is going to do is find this
principal component miss axis through
our data like this such that when we
look at the spread of a data
it's maximized right so the data is as
spread out as we can find it and this is
going to happen over any number of
attributes
so actually one here attribute to
attribute three attribute for all the
way
to attribute n when we've got maybe 700
or 800 or $1000 so at the moment which
is fitting one principal component this
is one line through our two-dimensional
data there's going to be more principal
components later right but what we want
to do is we want to pick the direction
through this data however many
attributes it has that has the most
spread so how do we measure this there's
really two goals which were exactly the
same one is to maximize the variance so
we find a direction for this line such
that these points at the very edge are
farthest apart the other one is that we
minimize the error so we take this error
from here this distance this distance
from all these points to our new axes
and we minimize it so you can imagine if
we do this for all our points we can get
the sum of the squared distances from
these points to this line and then as we
move this line around sometimes if it's
going to be better sometimes it's not if
we have a line that goes like this some
of these lines are going to be very
large like this and that's going to be a
higher amount of error so what we'll
find is that if we do this our first
principal component will sit through
whichever direction in the data
minimizes these distances and by
definition maximizes this spread which
makes this axis super useful if we use
this axis now as our new X and we rotate
this whole page all our data is lovely
and separated and actually we have two
distinct clusters in this data set right
so that's what we're going to do now as
I mentioned PCA doesn't typically reduce
the number of attributes from two to one
just like that we're going to have
another principal component which
represents the second amount of most
variance orthogonal e so at ninety
degrees so that's going to be this one
here we find the first principal
component which maximizes variance and
then we find the next one along that
maximizes events in the next direction
now if there were multiple dimensions
we'd keep applying this process we keep
finding new axes for our data that
systematically show more and more of a
spread of our data but we're crucially
we're ordering this by the amount of
variance that they represent so this is
PC one or principal component one this
is principal component two and principal
component one is always going to have
the most varied data in it
principal component to the next most
three the next most all the way to the
end with the least so a natural
side-effect of this process is that
we're going to have new axes through our
data which and we're going to have a
same number of axes as there are
original dimensions in our data but
they're going to get less and less
useful in terms of the variance of our
data as we go forward so PC one is going
to be the most important most of our
data is spread out across pc-1 pc2 a
little bit less spread out PC three a
little bit less still all the way down
to PC n all the way down here if you
wanted to perform dimensionality
reduction because you felt you had too
many dimensions to your data you could
just for example keep the first 10
principal components project your data
into that space and still retain most of
the information we won't go into the
mathematics of how to calculate these
principal components because you can
find out very easily online and all has
a lovely function to do it for us I
wanted to focus on intuitively what PCA
does but how we will actually project
these points onto these new axes and
rotate the whole thing is each of these
principal components is going to be a
weighted sum of all the attributes so
for example PC one is going to be some
amount of attribute one added to some
amount of attribute two now in this case
because it sort of goes off at sort of
45 degrees it's going to be about the
same but you could imagine if your data
was like this it'll be mostly attribute
one and a little bit of attribute two if
it was like this it'll be mostly
attribute to a little bit attribute one
all right now of course the
n-dimensional data or we have many more
dimensions that I can't draw on the page
the principle is exactly the same some
amount of attribute one attribute to
attribute three and so on all the way to
the end right and that's going to
project our points straight onto this
line through that data so when we talk
about minimizing the error you can
imagine rotating this about the center
of these points here like this and as
you do this these red lines are going to
change in length and it's going to
settle on the very center line where
these weights are minimized right and as
it happens that also maximizes the
variance of these points here because of
the fact that this mathematics is based
around eigenvectors and eigenvalues pc2
is always going to come out or foggin
all or in this case at 90 degrees to pc
one now this is true of however many
dimensions you've got every single new
axis that appears or new vector
a new principal component is going to
come out or foggin all to the ones
before until you run out of dimensions
and you can't do it anymore we've
already reached the most we can fit in
on this two-dimensional plane we've got
one here and we've got another one
orthogonal to it there is no other lines
I can draw for that to be true right but
obviously if we had more attributes that
would be the case so the reason that
it's so important to scare your data
appropriately is that you're trying to
find the direction for your data that
maximizes the variance now if one of
your dimensions is much much bigger than
the other of course that one is the one
that's going to maximize the variance if
you've got salary that's between naught
and 10,000 and all your others are
between naught and 1 then your first
principal component is going to be
predominately salary because that's the
most important thing as far as it know
if as it knows this is why it's so
important to standardize your data first
we're going to continue to use our music
data set for this video now for those of
you forgotten this data set is a set of
music files that are freely available
online where we've got the metadata of a
genres or titles for different tracks
and then for those tracks we've also
calculated some features about the
actual audio for example temporal
features how loud they are how fast the
music is how upbeat it is whether you
could dance to it this kind of thing
apparently dance ability is a measurable
trait apparently these teachers have
been generated by two different
libraries once called Lib rosa which is
freely available online and the other
ways echo nests which are the features
that a core of Spotify and how it does
its music recommender system and its
playlists so let's load the data set so
I'm going to read it it takes quite a
long time to load
it'll probably be faster if it wasn't in
a CSV you've got to remember if your
files are in CSV you've got to actually
pass the more than workout whether
they're numerical or text you know for
every cell okay so we've got 13,000
instances or rows in our data and we've
got 751 attributes or dimensions to our
data so these are going to include
features from both liberals ER and echo
nest and the other metadata of these
tracks so we're going to select just the
echo nest features for this part just be
it's a little bit easier to have fewer
dimensions to look at this would work
just as well
on all the other features as long as
they're numeric so we're gonna select
echo nest is equal to the music data
frame all of the rows and just the echo
nests columns which are 528 to the end
and then we're going to standardize all
this data now so we're going to Center
it around 0 a mean of 0 and a standard
deviation of 1 using the scale function
now take a minute to finish and then we
can just check to make sure that our
variance and our mean or what we
expected so we're going to apply over
dimension two so that's over all the
columns the variance function and find
out what the variances are and you can
see they're all one which is exactly
what we want so let's have a look at the
mean the mean should be centered about 0
it won't be exactly 0 just because of
you know floating point errors and so on
so there we go so 1.5 10 to the minus 17
very very small right close enough to 0
perfectly fine so the function we're
going to use is the PPR comp function in
R this is going to perform principal
component analysis for those of you who
are interested in learning more what
it's going to do is create a covariance
matrix and then it's going to use
singular value decomposition to find the
eigenvectors and the eigenvalues and
those are the things that actually we
want from a PCA so we're gonna run that
now it doesn't take too long but this is
still quite a live data set this will
slow down quite a lot if you had a very
very large data set but it still might
be worthwhile what it's done is it's
found the directions through our data
that maximize the variance and it's
projected our data into that space or
transformed our data into that space at
the moment the dimensionality of our
data is exactly the same and completely
unchanged no dimensionality reduction
has happened yet so let's perform a
quick summary there'll be a lot of the
stuff on the screen but I'll point
towards what's important so what it's
doing is it's showing us the list of all
the compiled
they're standard deviations service
spread in that direction and also how
much of the variance it accounts for you
can imagine that let's imagine a spread
of your data and all the different
dimensions is this much but in one
direction it's just this much what was
the percentage of the spread or the
variance that that principle component
accounts for right this is very easily
quantified so you can see in here we've
got the proportion of variance for PC
one is naught point one one six nine
which is about eleven point six percent
so out of all the 224 echo nest features
this weighted sum in principal component
one or vistit direction through our data
represents eleven percent of us bread
which it's not too bad actually I think
that's pretty good
why principal component two that's
another eight percent so the cumulative
proportion of these two principal
components is going to be twenty percent
and at printed component three
twenty-five percent and so on so what
we're saying is by the time we get to
principal component three if we
represent our data is this three
dimensional space around these axes pc-1
pc2 PC three we're getting 25 percent of
a spread of the data
that we had before but that's three
dimensions instead of two hundred and
twenty four dimensions so that's not too
bad now one important thing to look out
for is where our spread starts to get
towards a hundred percent where is it in
our data set that we can say you know
what these later dimensions these later
principal components are not really
adding anything to our data set so we
scroll down and we'll find here at 95
percent scroll down a bit further 98
percent 98 percent and here we go
principal component 133 the cumulative
proportion of variance explained by all
of those ones from 1 all the way to 133
is 99 percent if you're going to perform
dimensionality reduction stopping at 99
percent of the variance is very common
what we're saying is we can delete any
of our data from principal component 134
all the way to the end and we're still
getting 99 percent of a spread or
information from our dataset if you want
to use PCA for data reduction then what
you're going to have to do is decide
what your cutoff is going to be now 99
percent is a good number to use what
does that actually mean what it means is
if we plotted the different principal
components going this way and the amount
of barrier
it's that they explain like the amount
of a spread of a data that they're
responsible for they're going to
decrease like this I mean this is going
to be a bar chart actually right so like
this so principal component one is
always going to be the most variance
explained because that's how the
mathematics works these are ordered in
that way principal component 2 is less
three is less four is less and so on
we're going to keep going down until 99%
of the variance has been explained in
some band and we can remove everything
else that's what we're going to do so
99% is one option ninety-five percent
something like this any number of
principal components that you remove is
going to delete some of your data
equivalent to the moving dimensions but
because they're ordered in this way from
the most useful to the least useful it
just makes that job a little bit easier
instead of saying it was tempo or
feature five that we didn't want
actually we're saying in this axis
principal component one and principal
component to its principal component one
hundred and thirty-four that it's not
that useful to us let's have a look at
one of our principal components and see
what it is so we're going to type PCA
followed rotation and we're going to
select just the first one because
otherwise it's going to be too much
information so this is going to be how
much of each of our 224 dimensions does
pc1 need to create this weighted sum and
project our data so you can see for
example it's - naught point naught one
of tempo or two - two - naught point
naught two of tempo or two - three one
thing to remember about these is these
are now arbitrary axes through some
massively dimensional space very
difficult to know exactly what this
means right you can start to look into
based on these weights which of these
features is more useful but that's kind
of a second second step you can use so
for example tempo or feature naught is
no point naught - so we're going to take
naught point naught to eight times tempo
or not whatever that value is times like
this much of the next one times by this
much of the next one I'm gonna add them
all up and that is a projection of our
data point into this new space so we can
do this for our entire data set as it
happens
our calculates is forced but you could
calculate this using a matrix
multiplication if you wanted so these
are all our points transformed into this
new space so hopefully we can see them
better then we're going to start
plotting different genres of music in
these principal components to see if if
the separation is any better than it was
before so let's have a quick look
so this is a scatter plot a principal
component 1 vs. principal component 2
and every single song in our data set
and you can see it's a bit of a
higgledy-piggledy mess and it would be
because there's some 13,000 songs here
but you can see that maybe some of these
songs are bigger over here and some of
these over here maybe let's just look at
a few genres to sort of narrow it down
and make our figure a little bit clearer
so I'm going to select just a rock
electronic and classical genres I don't
know they seem like they'd be slightly
different so let's run that so we're
going to take just those genres we're
gonna plot them in the same scatter plot
and see where they are in this space so
how did this data get into this form
what happened was for every individual
track we had a number of features in our
224 dimensional space each of these
principal components is a weighted sum
so for example for let's say track 516
we'd have taken tempo feature 1
multiplied it by part of principal
component 1 the loadings added that to
the next bit to the next bit to the next
bit and worked out where it sits in
terms of principal component 1 this new
axis we'd have done the same for
principal component 2 and that puts them
down here now there's quite a lot of
overlap but you can start to see we're
teasing apart the electronic music from
the rock music the rock music's sitting
over here on the right the electronic
music sitting on the lower left and the
classical music has up the top here now
these axes don't mean you know that
musics faster or slower or more or less
upbeat because without looking into the
waiting's and below dings for these
principal components it's impossible to
say for sure but what we can say is that
they're starting to come apart and there
are some differences in our data set the
fact that they still overlap means that
probably two dimensions is not enough to
satisfactorily separate out all these
things if you wanted to pass this
projected and transform data into a
machine learning algorithm you'd
probably need to pass in more than two
dimensions and in this case given that
90% or 99% of the variance is explained
after principal compare 133 those 133
dimensions are probably what you'd use
you can actually use the entire output a
PCA the same number of dimensions you
have before to just show a better
rotated version of your data to a
machine learning algorithm you don't
have to remove any dimensions if you
don't want to but because the dimensions
are ordered
in from most variants to least you can
kind of get a good gauge for where you
should cut off and remove data that way
this kind of data reduction along with
the ones we looked at before are going
to form part of this data cleaning data
transformation and data reduction
approach that we're going to iterate
through until our data is as small as we
can get it and it's it's we can extract
as much knowledge as possible in the
easiest way once we're done with this
our date will be ready for clustering
for machine learning for classification
for aggression for anything else that we
want to do today we're going to talk
about clustering do you ever find when
you're on YouTube you'll watch a video
on something and then suddenly you're
being recommended a load of other videos
that you hadn't even heard of that are
actually kind of similar this happens to
me I watch some video